joining me here on the show back here on
the program always enjoyed chatting with
this man always enjoy trying to raise
money on behalf of his remarkable
charity along with Rudd and Stonestreet
and David Koechner and Rob Riggle the
big select charity in Kansas City for
Children's Mercy Hospital it's an
amazing charity everyone should pay
attention to it and give they just had
an amazing fundraiser virtually and
socially tournament of laughs we all
need a laugh no doubt about it the new
comedy competition premiering on TBS
this Sunday night at 10:00 Eastern Time
Jason Sudeikis how are you sir better
for talking to you how's life I
appreciate good great tournament of
laughs sir now is this should we get our
brackets like it's like it's March
Madness is this is well what do we have
here Jason yeah I mean that was the
impetus for the for the show from the
folks that came up with it was yeah in
the missing March Madness you know and
all the gambling exploitation of
comedians I think is a much easier thing
to swallow I agree with you so yeah so
is it so there could be upsets where
initially a comedian comes out does a
set doesn't look like it's worthy of a
top seed and then all of a sudden
Cinderella comes out and and wins the at
that moment walk me through the
competition here yeah absolutely yeah
it's 32 feet or they're making homemade
videos you know whether they're doing
their stand-up in a you know different
settings there's you know laying in bed
like Paul Rodriguez or you know doing
characters and then yeah they've already
been seated so be you know one versus
eight seeds and then yep playing it all
the way down through the bracket just
like any good you know competition show
America gets the boat on the Internet if
they have access to that there's yeah
folks do now and so yes there absolutely
could be an upset you know someone I
don't know the odd the Vegas odds at
this point and where they're putting
things but but I assume you know that'll
that'll be humming after no doubt so
does each region have is named after a
famous comedian like a Carlin region or
a Hackett region side gig
no been a fun little joke where just the
idea of where each each comedian what
region they fall in has absolutely
nothing to do with where they are where
they're from okay much like the Indians
the SS saying we have your east to west
yourself and then unknown probably
Canada for the poor reason the north hey
look it's a North American thing that
you're you're trying to expand it I
totally I totally get it though this
sounds like a lot of fun man that sounds
like a lot of fun Sunday 10:00 Eastern
on TBS tournament and laughs premiers
and then a charitable donation is going
to be made to the United Nation
Foundation's kovat 19 solidary response
fund and black lives matter as well so
this is a fundraiser to Jason correct
yeah and a fun to watch all the videos
and I'm like you know your old center
gig you know I'm just talking head you
know I get the throws are the funny ones
and then when it comes back to me and
I'll try to say little bon mots and you
know send it to the for the real money
is that the advertisers a man you're
talking to an old-school guy here Jason
huh I remember growing up a show called
make me laugh I think a comedian named
Bobby van was the host of it and there
was a whole bunch of people comedians
I'd have to come out and make make
people laugh and either advanced or not
I watched that all the time I'm just I
do I I'm an aficionado of competition in
comedies when I'm saying sir yeah golly
that made me just have a flashback to my
freshman year at rockers high school
where they had a make me laugh
competition where I was charged as being
equivalent quote funny
freshman to make a senior like football
player laugh yeah I just
I ate Dukie ate doing
not did not turn out well you know I
know I mean I don't think not only did
he not laugh I think all the laughing
happened at me after I was done with my
minute I blocked it out I hadn't thought
about that until I immediately had like
a rat tattoo a moment where I just
zoomed backwards and be like this dark
corner of my brain I was like I'll be
done well he died you know but you know
a 15 year old that thinks they're funny
usually isn't but look who's laughing
now Jason Sudeikis right you know I'm
saying I know that's maybe you know
that's all I'm saying look who's
laughing are you doing a lot of dramas
recently rich you know that's really
where my brother stood and you are also
digging into you're also digging into
your past here back into your your
premier league history coach Ted Lhasa
oh I do believe had a stent with
Tottenham Hotspur back in the day he's
back in the mix he's back on the pitch
that true story yeah yeah he sure is you
know in a big bold you know way for over
those commercials we made back in
2013-2014 where you know topped out
about five minutes but yeah we've got a
10 episode you know 30 minutes a piece
you know 300 minutes and Ted lasso just
coming up on Apple Plus mid-july eyes
you know when I say mid-july
that's a mid-august August 14th yeah so
that's looking forward to that that's
that's a yeah the mustache does all the
acting Ted lasso I mean that's a good
one I like lasso was a it was an
excellent choice Jason I think I assumed
that you'd land it on that now you
landed on that one back in the day to
try and figure out what's the most
American name you can sit send to the
Premier League on behalf of NBC Sports
that's the way to go I think Ted lasso
yeah a noun is the last name you know
that's
I know brother I know so hey look this
is gonna be fun the tournament of laughs
coming up on Sunday at 10:00 Eastern
Time on on TBS and then Ted lasso coming
to Apple TV Plus on August 14th there's
been a lot of former old SNL's that are
airing just like you know some old
sporting events that I've seen myself
pop up on every now and then what what
SNL that have you just been sitting at
home and Quarantine pop up and there you
were and you're you you forgot you did
it or it was a good memory lane stroll
for you Jason oh that happens all the
time
I just had the had the chance to be bid
that was one rap called round ball rock
where I played John cash and Ben
Robinson a great writer performer from
from SNL and Detroiters and was a great
show on Netflix now but the other thing
he wrote we played the Tesh brothers
it's all about you know me playing the
keyboards and him they'll be the unknown
lyrics to that sketch that I hadn't I
hadn't watched probably since midnight
we did it and even then I'm not watching
it I'm just saying it and it just
tickled me to know and then fall I'm
playing the straight man for us which he
obliged kindly and during his hosting
gig but yeah every time I watched those
things it is a little bit like a it's
like looking at an old yearbook and I
can sort of I can usually tell by my
attitude at the 1901 we're always and
goodbye how much I can usually say oh
yeah I think I drank Wednesday Thursday
and Friday night I look I look tasty and
heavy you know I was I look like a pale
peanut M&M you know not a good look for
television specialist you know 4k but
just that is a great bit and concept and
beat to play on with did John Tesh
brothers riding round ball rock I don't
know if you've ever seen the video of
John playing that live in concert and he
plays that have you seen this where he
plays the the the voicemail message he
once left himself or with an idea for
the music for the song have you ever
seen that Jason yes yeah I actually have
not in a while but I think we watch that
around that time of geena's gasps yeah
he plays with his whole body oh my god
he really gets into it man there's no
doubt about it
hey Jason I know I know that you got a
run enjoy Father's Day enjoy Father's
Day this weekend and what and and the
debut of your show on Sunday night I'll
be out there watching I appreciate it
man thanks for having us great chatting
you got it that's Jason Sudeikis
Tournament of laughs Sunday June 21st at
10:00 eastern time on TBS
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here